- Dans la dernière année,
ça a complètement explosé.
On a vu justement un 30 %
d'augmentation à peu près
dans les ventes de sans-alcool.
Les demandes sont grandissantes,
mais aussi la production
est grandissante.
- Les boutiques Cheers
tiennent une trentaine de bières
de microbrasserie sans alcool.
- Trèfle-Noir,
en Abitibi, Rouyn-Noranda,
c'est une des meilleures bières
sans alcool que j'ai bues.
- Des brasseurs bien établis,
comme Boréale, ont ajouté
une offre de produits
sans alcool à leur gamme.
D'autres ne produisent même
que des bières non alcoolisées,
comme BSA, par exemple.
CATHERINE ROUX,
cofondatrice de Boutique Cheers
- On s'attend maintenant
à une nouveauté par deux
semaines, par une semaine.
C'est vraiment intéressant, là.
On en tient puis on n'en tient
pas beaucoup. Il y en a beaucoup
plus sur le marché québécois
actuellement.
- Selon elle, le créneau
pourrait occuper 10 à 15 %
du marché total de la
microbrasserie d'ici
quelques années.
- On va s'attendre à une
explosion. Le 30 % de cette
année est vraiment juste une
bribe de ce qui va se passer.
Nous, on a l'intention de tenir
un frigo complet de bières sans
alcool seulement québécoises
et nos coups de coeur seulement.
Donc, on s'entend qu'il va
y avoir une bonne offre.
- Il faut dire que
les consommateurs ne sont
plus seulement les femmes
enceintes ou les gens qui
prennent des médicaments.
De nombreux amateurs
veulent simplement diminuer
leur consommation d'alcool.
SYLVAIN CHARLEBOIS, professeur,
Université Dalhousie
- Les gens vont peut-être
vouloir se remettre en forme
et faire attention à ce qu'ils
mangent, ce qu'ils boivent.
- La légalisation du cannabis
a aussi joué un rôle.
- Les ventes au détail dépassent
à peine 3 milliards au Canada,
mais quand même, il y a
une croissance de 25 à 30 %
par année. T'sais, un moment
donné, de boire de l'alcool
et de consommer du cannabis,
ça va pas bien ensemble.
Fait que les gens font le choix.
- Le pub St-Bock, sur la rue
St-Denis, a lancé la marque
Bazaar en novembre dernier
en plein coeur de
la deuxième vague.
MARTIN GUIMOND, propriétaire
du St-Bock et de Bazaar
- Il y en a environ une dizaine
de sortes, on va en avoir
une quinzaine de sortes. Ici, il
y en a seulement quelques-unes.
Pour vrai, faire de la bière
sans alcool, ça a été
la planche de salut du St-Bock.
- La microbrasserie vend
environ 400 caisses par mois
de ses produits non alcoolisés.
- C'est peut-être parce qu'on
est petits, mais on fournit pas.
Donc, on produit le plus
de choses possible. Et puis,
chaque fois que c'est prêt,
c'est déjà parti dans le camion.
Et puis, en quelques jours,
quelques semaines, toutes
nos caisses de bières sont déjà
écoulées dans les 150 points
de vente.
- Bazaar utilise une levure
spéciale qui empêche les sucres
de se transformer en alcool,
une procédure plutôt complexe,
utilisée surtout par
les petites microbrasseries.
- Faire de la bière, c'est
un art. Faire de la bière sans
alcool, c'est doublement un art.
Demander à une bière
de fermenter et de ne pas faire
d'alcool, c'est difficile.
- Les marques à grand
volume sous-traitent plutôt
leur production en Ontario
où les usines brassent
leur bière normalement puis
la désalcoolisent chimiquement.
- C'est bon?
- Oui.
- Martin Guimond, lui, veut
continuer d'utiliser le procédé
plus artisanal, mais il rêve
déjà de déménager la production
dans un plus grand espace
pour profiter pleinement
de la tendance.
Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-Canada, M